The question of 2023 is what is it related to?
What have you been told? Which of the following are
not under the control of the
thyroid hormone? Which function
is not related to your thyroid hormone? This is
your question of 2023: Maintenance of
water and electrolyte balance regulation.
Off Basal Metabolic Rate Normal Rhythm of
Sleep Wake Cycles A Development of Immune
System and Support the Process of RBC
Formation So what should be the answer? Our
ideal is Geetanjali Rakesh. If B is correct for you also
then yes son if you
talk about your correct answer.  So that is your B
option which is your normal rhythm of sleep and
cycle that is related to your
melatonin hormone and development of
immune system that is related to your
thymosin hormone right okay